can you describe what it was like
witnessing that test well it's been
described so many times it's hard to
when can I be very original about it but
the impressive thing is of course that
flash of light it's how do you expected
it did you I mean you I know you had
glass over your eyes you obviously
expected something but was it was it -
nothing
well it was much more than one could
possibly expect it yes we were actually
about a minute before the thing was
scheduled to go off titter ton and I
were there in that main control bunker
and and we were in charge of the so
called fast timing sending out timing
signals to the various experiments
during the last milliseconds before
other thing was go off and we also sent
the send out the Paulson that triggered
the thing off
but that was all senses in the last 100
milliseconds they were dealing with it
was all automatic and a minute or so
before I was scheduled to go off my
dinner tenses jested that I go outside
and have a good look and well being
young and no responsibilities so I I
went out and and along with three or
four other people just to get Kowski I
remember among them we stretched out on
the ground and and watch the thing how
far away were you six months it's ten
thousand yards but no one uses yards
anymore which is just slightly are less
than six miles and directly south and
the winds were prevailing away from the
west so all the the mushroom cloud and
where the oid debris and so on went
perpendicular to our line of sight it
may have been described many times
before but it's an extraordinary thing
to a witness that first bugs you know I
know it's a yeah
it's a little one cannot really describe
it because it's so impressive
my first comment was to after the thing
went off was was to a an MP who was at
the door of the main control bunker I
don't know why he was there but you know
he was supposedly to control access but
you wouldn't know who was to be let in
it was not to be like that I know about
it he after they explosion he no one had
told him what to expect and he was just
just totally white and so my comment to
him was that the world will soon be over
and of course it was that comment the
wall was in behavior was that impressed
upon you by the blast I mean presumably
you knew what no the fact that it was
that it worked anyone think like that it
worked and such an enormous blast yeah
at 6 miles away it takes about 30
minutes for I'm sorry 30 seconds for the
sound wave to travel that distance and
of course a corresponding number of
micro seconds for the light to reach him
so after the flash of light had begun
damn I I stood up he got a better view
of the rising mushroom cloud and then
realized the shockwave had another front
then we got back quickly got back down
on the crack but it is a rather curious
thing to see the something happened and
then you don't are not aware of it
really until 8 minutes rather I'm sorry
30 seconds later I said eight minutes
because that's the length of time it
takes lighter
reach of the Earth from the Sun
did you see the sound wave traveling
towards you did you see anyone no no
there's nothing there's nothing to
observe there was just this suddenly
this pulse of wind and then the
reverberation of the sound in the
mountains nearby he can just rumbled on
like heavy thunderstorm if I had been
standing I don't know if I'd been
knocked down but some people claimed
they were a bit of an exaggeration I
think